what's the most exciting thing about
joining the mcu with madame webb
but i can't talk about it
is that exciting i feel like that's hard
it's so hard because i talk so much
such a reaction when you got that call
though so scared anything i say i'm
gonna get in trouble
but it was amazing it was incredible i'm
so excited we've all been working really
really hard and
i'm just really really
honored to be able to be a part of this
it's crazy almost got snipers i get it
so don't worry it's yeah it's terrifying
it's terrifying but it's good it's good
hello huh happy to be here we're on our
honeymoon you're such a valued guest
welcome to the white lotus fans are a
huge fan of this show but now the
hollywood critics association says you
guys are best cable drama how does that
feel i mean
amazing like
humbling
really
surprising yeah it's very uh it was a
you know it was a lot of hard work and
passion put into the show and so
the love is surprising yeah miss working
with these two
of course i miss everyone i love mike
white the entire team we had it was such
an incredible cast and crew so i missed
them all up next the emmys of course
connie i got a chance to congratulate
you i mean sydney congratulations on
your first emmy nomination two in one
year
has it sunk in yet
no
i don't know will it ever oh i don't
think so but it's amazing yeah what
advice do you have for going into her
first semis you've been there before
you've been nominated before
um just you know i know what you'll
already do which is you're gonna go have
a great time and no don't put too much
pressure on yourself just have fun
just enjoy it yeah well you'll be there
so we'll have a good time yeah isn't
that the best though four co-stars right
from white lotus are in the same
category so it's gonna be a party don't
you feel well it'll be it'll be a
celebration no matter what experience
for sure for sure which is the beauty
what can you tease about the second
season of wow um
as unexpected and surprising and sharp
and funny and um
and uh hopefully as great as the first
one but yeah i'm really excited for
people to see it i'm
it's it's it's wild yeah i love so much
about the show is that going into it i
knew nothing about it and you got to
just experience it as it was happening
and then you just wanted to keep
watching more and more so i'm glad
there'll be another i think will be yeah
i think it'll have it has that same kind
of addictive quality in when you watch
that first episode you'll have no idea
where it ends up so it's exciting
congratulations and happy early birthday
you're celebrating at the emmys right oh
my god you know 25 yes thank you what a
birthday present i know it's crazy i
would but i know but i only get one plus
one so my mom and my dad are fighting
right now how do you choose i know i
know
i was like it's my birthday cause i have
an extra ticket
[Music]
you